Let's now talk about internet routing security or problems involving
securing the internet's routing protocol. We will primarily focus on
inter-domain routing or the security of BGP. We will
further focus on control plane security. Which typically involves
authentication of the messages being advertised by the
routing protocol. In particular, the goal of
control plane security, or control plane authentication
is to determine the veracity of routing
advertisements. There are various aspects of the
routing protocol that we seek to verify.
One, is session authentication, which protects the
point-to-point communication between routers. A second type
of control plane authen, authentication is path authentication,
which protects the AS path, and sometimes other attributes. Another type
of authentication is origin authentication. Which protects the origin
AS in the AS path; effectively guaranteeing that the
origin AS that advertises a prefix is, in fact, the owner of that prefix.